bonjour un maître merci d'être avec nous
en direct ce matin sur rtl france les
conclusions de la défenseure des droits
sont elles une bonne nouvelle pour votre
client
du moins on est satisfait de pouvoir
lire pour une fois un document qui est
complet en ce sens qu'il décrypte des
différentes scènes de violence qui dont
théo a été victime la presse l'opinion
publique s'est beaucoup focalisé sur le
coup de matraque
mais en réalité ce que a toujours
expliqué théaux c'est qu'il y avait au
moins trois scènes de violence celle de
l'interpellation qui donne le coup de
matraque
une autre scène dans lequel il est
effectivement maintenu au sol et frappé
par les policiers et une troisième scène
de violence alors qu'il est interpellé
et menotté et qui continue au
commissariat pour la première fois on a
un document qui met tout ça en
perspective et qui pointe effectivement
l'absence de proportionnalité et
l'absence de nécessité des violences
donc on se satisfait si vous voulez des
deux documents récents qui sont sortis
dans cette information le réquisitoire
du parquet dans l'information judiciaire
et ce rapport qui était très attendu qui
a donné lieu à beaucoup d'auditions
beaucoup de d'investigation et qui vient
confirmer les dires de la victime qui a
beaucoup souffert depuis quatre ans de
désinformation orchestrée par une partie
malheureusement des syndicats de police
alors que vaut justement ce rapport de
la défenseure des droits sur le plan
judiciaire
alors la défenseure des droits c'est une
autorité administrative indépendante
c'est effectivement pas l'autorité
judiciaire et si j'étais avocat des
policiers
je vous ne voudrais pas qu'on confonde
les deux procédures
cependant c'est tout de même une
autorité qui a fait un rapport encore
une fois extrêmement complet à ses
objectifs et donc ça va être un document
très utile au débat judiciaire qui va se
dérouler dans les prochains mois donc
c'est un document est un travail qui va
nourrir la justice en ce sens que on ne
cherche pas à opposer des thèses
on cherche à savoir véritablement ce qui
s'est passé on allait
vidéos de surveillance on a les
témoignages on a les expertises et
maintenant on a aussi le travail d'une
autorité administrative indépendante qui
demande d'un côté l'autorité politique
de tirer les sanctions administratives
qu'on peut déjà tirer à partir de ce
rapport et qui sera une pièce du dossier
dans le cadre du procès qui doit
intervenir
justement vous parlez de des vidéos dans
cette affaire vous savez qu'à une loi le
projet de loi de sécurité globale dont
qui a été adopté hier par les députés
c'est un texte polémique jugée
controversée par beaucoup par des
journalistes mais pas seulement
d'abord que pensez vous de ce projet de
loi et puis est-ce que cela peut tout la
polémique autour justement du texte peut
avoir une influence sur cette affaire
sans votre affaire non je pense que
c'est en matière de libertés publiques
toujours une question d'équilibré
l'équilibré entre d'un côté la nécessité
et on la comprend bien d'assurer
l'efficacité de la sécurité des français
en permettant à la police d'intervenir
en protégeant les conditions de sécurité
des policiers et de l'autre la
possibilité d'informer pour les
journalistes est fondamental dans une
démocratie mais aussi le droit d'une
personne quand elle constate une
infraction sous ses yeux de pouvoir sans
constituer une preuve
donc ce qui est discuté c'est cet
équilibre là on voit bien dans le
dossier théo qu' il est tout est s
contre un mental que les citoyens mis
dans une situation et présente une
illégalité puisse filmer les policiers
et je crois que le texte dit bien que si
ces faits dans un autre but c'est
interdit mais si ces faits dans le but
de se préserver une preuve devant des
faits de violence c'est autorisé donc je
crois qu'il faut arriver à savoir dans
quelle logique ce texte de loi va
s'inscrire
ça c'est pour le texte de loi maintenant
aux états unis les policiers
interviennent avec des caméras dans
toutes les démocraties du monde
il n'est pas interdit de filmer des
policiers tant que l'on préserve leur
leur droit aussi je crois que dans cette
procédure les droits des policiers ont
été préservés ils ont été mis en examen
ils ont eu le droit à une procédure
équitable à la possibilité de faire
valoir les moyens mais heureusement
heureusement il y a des éléments
objectifs ses vidéos ses témoignages ces
expertises qui permettent à la victime
de violences policières de faire
entendre sa cause parce que sinon et
c'est particulièrement vrai dans les
dossiers qui concernent l'autorité
judiciaire ou qui concerne la police si
vous voulez si c'est parole contre
parole la parole de la victime ne
peuvent rien du tout donc on a la même
problématique avec les affaires
impliquant la police que celle
impliquant par exemple la magistrature
et dans ce cadre je crois que protéger
la possibilité pour une personne de se
constituer une preuve est quelque chose
de tout à fait fondamental les suites
judiciaires pour théo luhaka il ya un
procès dont qui sera prévu qu'elle est
prévue l'année prochaine vous êtes
confiant en terminer alors il n'y a pas
de procès prévu l'année prochaine pour
le moment on est au stade de la fin de
l'information judiciaire en attend donc
l'ordonnancé du juge d'instruction qui
va dire s'il ya procès ou non
et qui va dire devant telle juridiction
et ce quelles qualifications
il est vrai que tous les éléments de ce
dossier depuis le début nous avons
beaucoup de travail et pour pouvoir
offrir à la juridiction qui sera saisi
de ce dossier si le juge d'instruction
le décide
une vision disséquer globale précise qui
permettra j'espère encore une fois de
rendre la justice c'est à dire qu' il
s'agit parade de punir il s'agit pas de
sanctionner
il s'agit de dire ce qui s'est passé et
d'en tirer les conséquences judiciaires
avec le respect des droits tant pour les
victimes que pour les mis en cause
merci beaucoup m antoine iv d'avoir
répondu en direct à nos questions sur rt
france d'être l'avocat de théo luhaka